MUCH.
>> YEAH, THANK YOU.
>> Brian: MEANWHILE,
PROTESTERS IN FLORIDA ARE
DENOUNCING BRENDA SNIPES.
YOU SAW THAT SPLIT THE
SCREEN.
I SHOULD HAVE EXPLAINED THAT
TO YOU.
PEOPLE GOING CRAZY.
THE BROWARD COUNTY
SUPERVISOR OF ELECTIONS.
[CHANTING]
>> SUPERVISE YOUR OWN
CORRUPTION.
>> Brian: SO WHO IS BRENDA
SNIPES AND WHY IS SHE
PROVOKING SUCH A STRONG
REACTION?
WHY DOES SHE STILL HAVE A
JOB?
LISA BOOTH IS A SENIOR
FELLOW OF THE INDEPENDENT
WOMEN'S VOICE SHE JOINS US
RIGHT NOW FROM UNDISCLOSED
LOCATION.
I JUST SAW YOU, LISA, WHY
AREN'T NEW STUDIO.
>> Lisa: I'M IN D.C.
VISITING FAMILY.
>> Brian: YOU ARE SUPPOSED
TO CHECK IN WITH ME.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> Brian: WHO IS THIS WOMAN.
>> SHE WAS APPOINTED BY JEB
BUSH IN 2003.
SHE IS A DEMOCRAT AND
ELECTED EVER SINCE TO THE
POSITION OF THE SUPERVISOR
OF ELECTIONS FOR BROWARD
COUNTY.
BROWARD COUNTY IS THE SECOND
MOST POPULIST COUNTY IN THE
STATE.
IT IS ALSO THE MOST DEMOCRAT
AS WELL AND IT'S NOT JUST
REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE BEEN
CRITICAL OF HER EITHER.
THE MIAMI HERALD CALLED
BROWARD COUNTY THE MOST
CONTROVERSIAL DEPARTMENT OF
ELECTIONS IN FLORIDA.
SO SHE HAS ALSO RECEIVED
WIDE CRITICISM FROM ALL
AROUND.
REALLY DATING BACK TO EVEN
2004 WHERE SHE FAILED TO
SEND OUT I THINK IT WAS
SOMETHING LIKE OVER 50,000
ABSENTEE BALLOTS FROM
INDIVIDUALS HAD REQUESTED
THEM.
ALSO JUST LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED IN THIS YEAR ALONE.
A JUDGE JUST RULED THAT SHE
WAS IN VIOLATION OF PUBLIC
RECORD LAWS FROM FLORIDA FOR
NOT FULFILLING RICK SCOTT'S
CAMPAIGN'S REQUEST.
YOU ALSO GO BACK TO MAY.
AND A FEDERAL JUDGE FOUND
SHE WAS IN VIOLATION OF BOTH
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW FOR
ILLEGALLY DESTROYING A
BALLOTS IN REGARD TO A 2016
PRIMARY BETWEEN DEBBIE
WASSERMAN SCHULTZ AND A
BERNIE SANDERS SUED AND MIND
YOU THE DESTROYING OF THESE
BALLOTS HAPPEN IN THE MIDST
OF A LAWSUIT SHE WAS FACING
REGARDING PUBLIC RECORDS
REQUESTS, REGARDING THOSE
BALLOTS.
SO, THAT'S KIND OF SKETCHY.
AND THEN YOU ALSO GO BACK TO
AUGUST AND A JUDGE RULED IN
FAVOR OF THE FLORIDA G.O.P.
THAT SHE WAS PRIVATELY
LOOKING AT ABSENTEE BALLOTS
SO THAT THEY COULDN'T BE
CONTESTED OR LOOKED AT BY
OTHER PEOPLE, A JUDGE RULED
IN FAVOR OF THE FLORIDA
G.O.P. REGARDING THAT.
SHE HAS ALSO GOTTEN IN
TROUBLE FOR RELEASING VOTING
INFORMATION 30 MINUTES PRIOR
THAN THE CLOSING OF THE
POLLS.
>> Brian: THAT WAS 2016.
>> ACTUALLY THE SAME PRIMARY
WHERE SHE GOT IN TROUBLE FOR
DESTROYING THE BALLOTS WITH
DEBBIE WASSERMAN SCHULTZ.
SO THERE HAS BEEN A WHOLE,
YOU KNOW, A WHOLE THING,
EVEN DATING BACK TO 2004
THAT SHE HAS RECEIVED
CRITICISM OVER.
AND IT'S NOT JUST FROM
REPUBLICANS.
>> Brian: LISA, NOT ONLY IS
SHE DOING A BAD JOB.
ALMOST ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
STATE COULD BE DOING A
BETTER JOB.
SO I ASK THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE, I SAID WHY ISN'T SHE
FIRED?
THEY SAID IT'S A LOT HARDER
TO FIRE SOMEBODY IF THEY ARE
ELECTED.
IT'S MUCH MORE COMPLICATED
THAN LET'S SAY YOU OR I.
WE CAN GET FIRED RIGHT AWAY.
I GUESS IT'S A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THERE.
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT'S WHERE
THE FOCUS IS EXTREMELY BLUE
AREA.
YOU CANNOT BLAME THE SCOTT
CAMP FOR BEING WORRIED.
FINAL THOUGHT?
>> WELL, SHE COULD HAVE
REMOVED HER FOR
INCOMPETENCE.
THERE IS PRECEDENT FOR THAT
THE PERSON THAT WAS IN THAT
JOB BEFORE HER WAS REMOVED
FOR THAT VERY REASON.
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT'S
REALLY NOT THE APPROACH OF
RICK SCOTT ADMINISTRATION.
BUT I THINK IT'S VERY CLEAR
SHE IS INCOMPETENT AND THERE
IS A LOT OF QUESTIONS
REGARDING WHAT SHE IS DOING
IN BROWARD COUNTY.
>> Brian: ALL RIGHT.
LET'S SEE.
TOMORROW, SATURDAY AT NOON,
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO GET THE